Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Jim Freeman, who is author of the book
Rich Thanks to Racism How the Ultra Wealthy
Profit from Racial Injustice, and also director
of the Social Movement Support Lab at the
University of Denver.
Jim, it's so great to have you on today.
Speaker 3: Thanks so much for having me, David.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, to start with, let's
get people into sort of the thesis and idea
of the book and in what ways can racism be
profitable?
How do people monetize racism?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, you know, the reason
I wrote the book is I wanted to introduce
this idea of strategic racism, right.
So particularly after last summer, there's
a lot a lot more understanding of systemic
racism, which is which is good and exciting.
But the problem is that not many people understand
what and who stand in the way of dismantling
that.
And there's also a problem, too, I think,
with the term, which is just sort of vague
and impersonal.
It makes it seem like systemic racism is this
natural occurrence.
It's just sort of part of our society.
So I went and introduced this idea of systemic
racism to demonstrate to people that there
are people who are profiting from it.
There are people who are racism profiteers
in this country, that there is intentionality
behind these efforts, because even when we
do think that there's people on the other
side of this fight, we think about the right
and those kind of folks.
But that's not who's been passing all these
laws that are responsible for systemic racism,
that they're not the ones who are doing the
the heavy lifting in defending or expanding
these policies.
So my work as a civil rights lawyer has been
with the communities that are most impacted
by systemic racism, black and brown communities.
I've been working with those communities for
for 20 years.
And so I've seen up close what this looks
like and how devastating it is.
And what that really means in practice is
that these corporate and Wall Street executives,
these ultra wealthy billionaires, they make
huge investments in these think tanks and
advocacy organizations and media outlets that
have been instrumental in preserving, defending
and expanding these dynamics, such as what
we see in the criminal justice system, such
as what we see in education and immigration.
And and like you say, they are profoundly
profitable.
These dynamics for the ultra wealthy, they
make money off of mass incarceration and immigrant
detention and immigration enforcement and
school privatization.
And they also, you know, they pay less in
taxes when we as a society choose to dehumanize
people rather than meeting their basic human
needs.
And then one thing that became very clear,
I think, to a lot of folks last summer is
that systemic racism, particularly the mass
criminalization and incarceration system that
we have, is extremely effective at controlling
us, at dividing us and causing us not to recognize
our common interests.
And we really saw that in how police were
used to to really stamp down political protests.
So all those dynamics really help maintain
the status quo, help the ultrawealthy maintain
their political and economic power.
And those are just some of the ways that they
profit from these dynamics.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so and that I mean, that
gives us a good introduction to a lot of different
industries and corporations that are sort
of directly connected to a lot of these issues.
I'd be curious about your thoughts before
we go back to that about I don't know.
I don't want to use the term more like benign
or pedestrian corporations, but just things
more associated with day to day, like, for
example, Starbucks and other companies that
last summer started to make a big show of
we're going to do implicit bias training and
all of our managers and maybe even employees
are going to go through a course and so on
and so forth.
I've always felt that that was essentially
a PR decision and and no one at its face,
it didn't really pass the sniff test for me.
But really what got me thinking that was I've
not really found evidence that that type of
training for a company like Starbucks just
to pick one or others, really gets at the
root of some of what is causing these issues
to begin with.
So I know that this is kind of a slight deviation
from what you introduced to us.
But what's your thought about that as as a
source of profit or at least of positive PR?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, you make an excellent
point, which is, you know, last summer we
had what seems like virtually every corporation
in America coming out with a statement denouncing
systemic racism.
Yes.
Proclaiming that black lives matter.
And yet here we are nine months later.
And what of those corporations done to actually
dismantle these systems?
Right.
To not just like you say, do these sort of
superficial diversity efforts or to donate
some small, tiny percentage of their profits
to black owned businesses?
I'm talking about real efforts to to address
these issues that are harming and even killing
people in black and brown communities.
They're nowhere to be found.
And in fact, for the most part, they're there.
They continue to be on the opposite side of
these fights.
So one thing that.
Then I talk a lot about is is, you know, those
we've had those types of efforts forever,
you know, where we we talk about how we're
making progress, right?
We're taking steps forward.
We've been doing that for over one hundred
years.
I mean, and it's got to be clear by now that,
you know, those things aren't bad persay,
but they're not even close to being enough
and.
You know, I think the question for us is how
many more people are we going to allow to
be harmed?
How many more lives are we going to allow
to be taken while we are content not to actually
solve the problem, but to merely make progress?
So I think when it comes to racial justice,
we need to remove the word progress from our
vocabulary.
I think it's time to advance real solutions,
but to do so, I think it's going to require
many more people understanding how and why
corporate America and Wall Street are able
to profit from other people's pain.
And we're going to need many more white people
in particular to understand how their struggles
are deeply interconnected with the struggles
of people of color so that they recognize
that the fight for racial justice is also
their fight.
Speaker 1: Now, when you talk about that interconnection,
I'm I'm leading here in the sense that I don't
think you're talking about a sort of class
reductionism of just realizing that in the
same ways that a lot of these racial issues
relate to class.
That can also be a factor for why you're talking
about a different type of interconnection.
Am I right?
Speaker 3: I am, yeah.
I mean, I think there's there's there's different
types of interconnection.
But but one was really only made apparent
to me when I was researching and writing the
book, which is as I was diving in the book,
is really an effort to sort of follow the
money behind systemic racism or I call strategic
racism to understand exactly where it's coming
from and the ideology behind it.
But as I was doing that, it was really Eye-Opening
for me, because, you know, as I as I was learning
more about where this money was coming and
how strategic these investments were, I also
realized how heavily invested the ultra wealthy
are in pushing a political agenda that's been
deeply harmful to white Americans as well.
Not in the same ways, of course, and not always
at the same levels.
Frequently not.
But but what I say is that if white people
examine the reasons that their lives are far
more difficult than they need to be, they
will likely eventually run into the same set
of organizations and individuals who are leading
the opposition against racial equality.
Yeah.
So I, for one, was astonished to discover
just how enormous an influence the ultra wealthy
have on my life and on every other white person
I know.
But then, yes, beyond that, like, we all need
to get to the point where we can clearly see
that education inequities and mass criminalization
and anti-immigrant policies and all these
other racial justice issues don't just harm
those who attend the under-resourced schools
or suffer the effects of overpolicing or or
face the prospect of being deported.
If we examine our lives carefully, we will
all find evidence of harm caused by the reverberations
from these unjust systems.
And on the flip side, we also need to recognize
that people were fighting for racial justice,
are trying to like we're often treated like
we're trying to ruin the world.
But the reality is we're trying to build a
better world that benefits all people and
that when we do address these issues of systemic
racism, it doesn't just help people of color
who have the burden of those racial inequities
lifted off them.
We all stand to benefit when our neighbors
are able to live higher quality lives and
really rot of injustice is purged from our
system.
Speaker 1: What are some examples of where
you think the most notable progress has been
made in the last 10 to 15 years on these issues?
Speaker 3: Well, you know, I think the most
exciting progress happening within most recent
memory is is around law enforcement and the
criminal justice system and people are really
starting to interrogate this issue of police
and the role that they serve and the role
that they should serve.
Right.
And people are asking questions, really important
questions about how we actually keep.
Are our communities safe and healthy, and
why have we tasked so much the police departments
with so much that really they're ill equipped
to handle?
I mean, that's certainly true in in black
and brown communities.
But but it's true beyond that, too.
I mean, I think we have to recognize how frankly,
how deeply we've lied to communities of color
over the year, made for 40 years.
Basically, what US policymakers have been
saying to black and brown communities is,
is this we can we can best keep you safe by
being tough on crime, by flooding your communities
with police officers, by using stop and frisk,
by employing broken windows, policing and
cracking down on the level of offenses, by
putting police in schools, by locking up people
at the highest rates anywhere in the world,
by doing the type of policing, frankly, that
killed George Floyd and Dante Wright and so
many others.
And all along, the consistent message has
been that these were the most effective strategies
for improving public safety.
But there is no evidence for that.
You know, there are no heavily police to high
incarceration communities that are flourishing
socially, economically culture.
There are just none.
It's a null set.
So it really is a deep, deep lie that that
we've been telling those communities for many
years and folks are starting to see through
it.
And I think that's very exciting
Speaker 1: when you think about some of the
decisions that are made by corporations that
are not directly involved.
For example, look at incarceration, as you
talked about, or some of these other specific
areas.
It seems that there is a kind of vicious cycle
where even, you know, a chain restaurant based
on how it decides where to put new restaurants
and as a result, where jobs are created and
what impact that has on the food choices of
people that may otherwise live in food deserts.
I mean, a lot of these things seem very complex
to me because one can find reasons to think
that almost any decision to give a really
specific example, think of a fast food chain
that says, hey, you know what we do well in
poor neighborhoods that are relative food
deserts in terms of other options, there's
not that many grocery stores are healthier,
healthier alternatives.
And so that's where we're going to go.
And this worsens the health of the people
in the neighborhood by making OK.
The counter, though, is, hey, they're creating
some jobs in that neighborhood, though.
If every such business decided we're not going
to set up shop in this neighborhood, that's
100 hundred.
That's two hundred.
However many jobs that that aren't brought
there.
And it very quickly becomes sort of like cloudy.
How what is the what should be the top level
interpretation of some of these business decisions
that relate to race?
How do we disaggregate that and start to pick
apart something, something like that?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, I think.
I think it's certainly true that we have to
become much more disciplined as a country
in analyzing all of those decisions and the
policies that influence those decisions through
the lens of race, through the lens of systemic
racism.
And I would suggest strategic racism, too,
because I'll go back to criminal justice,
because we were talking about it the last
summer when George Foy was killed, when he
was murdered, we were told over and over again
that it was a wake up call for the nation.
Right.
But we never actually woke up.
Right?
If we had, we would have started to have we
would have come together around real solutions
to those issues around the vastly oversize
and violent criminal justice system that's
used within black communities as a catch all
solution for a huge variety of behaviors.
We didn't actually do that.
We didn't even really start that conversation.
But it's not because we don't know how.
It's not because they don't have a fix like
we do.
And there is we don't do it because there's
a very well-funded opposition that stands
in the way.
Right.
So you have organizations like Alec representing
hundreds of the largest corporations in the
US working for decades to pass those various
tough on crime policies.
You have folks like the Koch brothers and
all these other billionaires who have been
pouring tens of billions of dollars into various
right wing think tanks and advocacy organizations
that have been pushing this agenda and still
do.
Today, you have one of those think tanks,
the Heritage Foundation, who after the uprising
last summer against systemic racism, what
they decided to do is launch a back to blue
campaign, a back to blue police pledge that
has now been signed by two hundred members
of Congress.
So that's two hundred members of Congress
who have vowed to continue supporting the
status quo in law enforcement.
Right.
And then one of those members of Congress,
Senator Tom Cotton, one of the most powerful
Republicans in the country, who tweets out
a couple of weeks ago that the US, we have
a major under incarceration problem.
So for me, that's what modern day racism looks
like, is that we implement these public policies
that we know are going to inflict needless
harm on large groups of people that we know
will perpetuate racial inequities that we
know will lead to people getting killed.
And then when that harm becomes apparent,
we fail to address it appropriately, in significant
part because it's economically beneficial
for the ultra wealthy.
So I think that's true in criminal justice.
I think that's true in education.
I think that's true and in public health.
And so what we really need to do is if we're
going to address those issues, we really need
to prioritize that and lift up those issues
and collectively start looking at these issues
through the lens of race so that we can start
to design our public policies in a way that
moves us towards the just and equitable society
that that all people deserve.
Speaker 1: The book is Rich Thanks to Racism
How the Ultra Wealthy Profit from Racial Injustice.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Jim Freeman.
Jim, so great having you on.
And I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 3: Thank you so much for having me.
David.